On our questions that people have said did that I want to go over before I open it up for questions.
Question that we commonly get commonly get is timing of supplements.
There are certain supplements that I recommend that does require specific timing.
Needing that you want to take them at a specific time of day or at a specific time of the day around what you're doing as far as food intake.
Beating that, some supplements it's okay to take with food, some supplements you want to take on an empty stomach, some supplements you want to take a couple hours after other supplements, some supplements you want to take right in the morning, some you want to take it night before you go to bed, some you want to take on an empty stomach.
So that does get very confusing, but if I've recommended a supplement to you and I haven't given you any data about you have want to take this on an empty stomach or this is a homeopath so you're taking this away from any time you have mint in your mouth.
Or this is a diet, this is an enzyme that we're using to help digest your cancer so we want to take this on a away from food from about from an hour away from food.
Or this is a supplement we're trying to get your liver to flush in a phase 2.5 phase 3 purpose so we want to take this after the bitters supplement if I didn't give you that data that it doesn't matter when you take the supplement.
So just so you know if I didn't give you specific data on when you should take a supplement that it really doesn't matter whether you take the supplement with food or not most of the supplements that we use are food based supplements so does it matter if you take it with food or not not really not really so is it sometimes better to take them outside of food so you don't quote unquote water down the supplement maybe.
But everybody's different sometimes people take supplements on an empty stomach that are good food based supplements so it shouldn't make any difference if they take them on an empty stomach but they get a tummy ache from them.
So you're going to have to try that yourself not everybody is the same so if I didn't give you specific data when to take it you can take it any time of the day.
Facebook rules we're getting a lot more people a lot more patients on our Facebook page which is wonderful.
We do have some rules now I'm not stating these rules because anybody's broken any rules because they haven't.
Matter of fact I think to she to post it something she said I'm not sure if this is right to post this it was about another individual that has cancer that she knows and
um that's fine to post things like that that you want somebody you know the we're a family and if we want to be prayed for someone that's really great.
Do remember though this Facebook page is primarily for our patients so though I appreciate it if you post something like that or I appreciate it if you
vote post maybe a question about your loved one or about your child understand that's not really what this is for.
So the Facebook page is for those who paid for a full plan so that's really what the purpose of it's for so try to keep to your
personal questions and your personal things that would inspire others on the board and think of it in that way we don't want it just to become a random Facebook page.
Either so I'm not saying anything man about anything it was posted up to this point time we just want to keep in mind that that piece that that it's for all of our patients.
Facebook questions this is again the Facebook page is for you to ask questions so and I purposely created it for there to be interaction.
I want you to be answering each other's questions and we see that all the time what a blessed it is so everybody's answering other people's questions and I do notice that like on the essential oils questions some people are very educated.
They've been doing essential oils for a long time Mike is one of those people and he's posting things on the essential oil page some different different ideas out of what a person could do.
And then he always puts it there very professionally please check with Dr. Connors about this for you and I thank you for that that should just be without saying we're not advocating or can the clinic advocate anything anybody else is doing even a recipe that they're using it might not be valid for you.
Make sure that you're checking your binder that a recipe that somebody else posts is not necessarily something you can eat everybody's on a different diet.
An essential oil that might be great for one person might not be great for another person so I don't want you as patients to not give your great insight to other people.
But I also don't want you to have to type in a little caveat that please ask Dr. Connors first that should just be that should just be a given so I want you to give your knowledge to other people.
But I also want that other person who's reading it to know enough to have enough common sense to know that boy if maybe this isn't what I should do and to ask me and my opinion.
And to make sure you look at the rules that we gave you with your diet to see if it fits as well.
And then our DNA kit is in so we know that a lot of people did the 23 of me and remember our software changed so we could read the 23 of me data so if you already did the 23 of me you do not need to do our new DNA kit but our new if you have not done the 23 of me yet.
Then we want you to do our DNA kit so contact our office if you have not done the 23 of me and you're ready to do a DNA kit and we want to get that done.
Now that DNA kit is to measure steps single nucleotide polymorphins those are genetic defects or genetic variants that we want to look at that have to do with cancer genes that we're talking about with in my mouth here.
Different things in your genes that can can be a piece of the cause of your cancer and can be the piece of the cure for your cancer so we want to get everybody's genetics run so if you haven't had your genetics either 23 in me or our kit make sure you contact our office so we can get a kit out to you.
Now I know Jed has called multiple people everybody on the list and quite honestly did not hear back from the vast majority of those people she left messages with so if you're on this call and you have not had your DNA run it's time to do that get a hold of the office so we could get a kit out to you.
And then lastly we had a number of IVG tests coming back in people doing it for their second third and even fourth time and we're starting to see these trends now that's where the beauty of the IVG comes in it's one thing to get an IVG score and great I have a score of 32 well I don't know what my score was before so I by trending up or am I trending down how is this goal.
I just don't know but when you start to get your second and your third test back and if we're trending up then we need to do some tweaking of what we're doing if we're trendy down then we are on the right track and we're doing the right things even though you might still be struggling with a lot of things we know that the cancer is starting to arrest.
So this is a DNA test.
So the DNA kit, or the 23 and me, or our DNA kit is measuring genetic defects or variants
on different genes.
The IV gene test is measuring free cell DNA, means circulating cells, it's measuring
circulating tumor cells, and on those circulating tumor cells, it's measuring, is the, are the
oncogenes, those are the genes that stimulate cancer growth, are they turned on, and are
the tumor suppressor genes, those are the genes that suppress that tumor, that turned
off a cancer, that's slow a cancer, are they turned on or off?
So the higher the IV gene score, that means the more of your oncogenes are turned on,
and the fewer suppressor genes are turned on, and the lower the score, the more oncogenes
are turned off, and the tumor suppressor genes are turned on.
So we want the tumor suppressor gene genes to be up-regulated, to be turned on.
We want the two or oncogenes to be down-regulated or turned off, that has to do with their methylated
or not.
So not to get too technical, we want a lower score, so we want our score to tread down.
So if it's tread-dead up, we need to tweak some things.
Now, plus or minus 5, 6, 8 points, not too worried about that, it can bounce around a little
bit, depending upon your stress levels, depending upon your diet, depending upon what you're
doing as far as nutrition goes, other things that are going out in your life, stimulation
of your immune system, suppression of your immune system, these are all things that could cause
cancer to grow or could cause cancer to slow.
So as we look at this over multiple tests, we want to look at the trend.
So we had another question just come in, a random question, is there anything unhealthy
about pop cord if made unestove with coconut oil?
Great question, is pop cord good for you or bad for you?
Well, number one, is it organic pop cord or is it regular pop cord?
If it's regular pop cord, it's going to be genetically modified cord.
So there is zero good things for you, genetically modified cord.
So period, it's organic pop cord with coconut oil, well, that's good then, right?
Well, cord is a grade, remember, it's not a vegetable, cord is a grade, it's not a vegetable.
So it's simply carbohydrates, is there any value in eating cord?
No, matter of fact, cord can also be a highly sensitive thing, meaning there's probably
the most food sensitive thing that most common food sensitivity is gluten, dairy, soy and
corn.
Maybe I could think of a few other things.
So is there any value in cord?
Is there anything, but the question was, is there anything unhealthy about eating?
Let's put it organic pop cord if made unestove come with coconut oil?
No, if that could be your stack and that's going to be your stack for the day, then go
for it.
I don't want to knock it because that could be or searching for something to eat here, right?
But don't call it something that's good for you.
So this is going to be your cheat stack, you're going to have a little pop cord with some
sea salt and it's organic and you made it with coconut oil so you're getting a good fat
with it.
So there's nothing really wrong with it.
Just make sure you don't have any sensitivity issues to cord.
How would I know that?
Well, you can run a test.
There's some different blood tests that we can do if you really want to know, if you have
any cord sensitivities, if you have any antibodies to cord and cord, different proteins and cord.
But you could also notice, do I get a tummy ache after I eat it?
Does it bother me?
Do I get a headache?
Do I get stuffy after it?
So you could notice if I have any symptoms after eating cord as well.
But otherwise, don't go ahead and ham that.
Understand it's a carbohydrate.
It's not a protein.
It's not a vegetable.